This is my first twerk class.
I'm so excited. Everybody wore
their best leggings.
So, Justine, Jojo,
let's twerk this thing.
All right.
See if things
will twerk out.
Hard twerk ethic.
Yeah, yeah.
Got to work hard.
Got to twerk hard.
Twerk all day.
Here we go.
Twerk it all day.
Twerk it all night.
Twerk it.
[ Justine ] Gorburger,
I need you to pay attention
on yourself,
not her butt.
No, what do you mean?
I'm not attracted to
anybody in here.
My genitals,
they're not compatible
with any human being,
so, ladies,
you're safe with me.
All right, now we're going to do
the basics for the wobble.
So, run in place first.
Okay, wobbling.
[ Justine ]
Just let it shake.
So you're just moving
the evacuator.
Yes. The evacuator only.
Let it shake.
[ Jojo ] All right,
let me see you roll your hips.
Can you roll your hips?
[ Gorburger ] I cannot.
I mean, I can do that.
[ Jojo ] Yes! Hey!
[ Justine ] Speeding it up.
[ Jojo ] Speed it up. Hey.
I'm moving as fast as I can.
Look at me go, Jojo.
All right,
go ahead and go down.
Arch your back.
Make sure your back is arched.
I cannot arch my back.
My vertebrae
are in a parallel line
and they are
fused together.
[ Justine ] Down and up.
Up and down.
[ Justine ] Or up and down.
You know, I thought this was
going to be so [ bleep ] stupid,
but it rules.
And, you know,
this is good for women.
Don't you think, girls?
No body shaming in
this [ bleep ].
No!
I do find that
when you eat a human being,
the butt meat
is the leanest.
Yet at the same time,
it tastes like shit.
[ music stops ]
Which I love.
What?